this is the moment
for you to show us what is real
[Music]
it's been 20 years since the first
matrix and
why was this the right time to go ahead
and return back to these characters
um i don't know the right time is
because it was the right time for the
director and writer
this is the right time for the director
and writer i mean but what about you two
what was it like the first day back on
set to sort of come back into this world
yeah it was it was amazing i mean we had
had some time training we trained for
about two months before we got onto the
set which is really helpful we did that
with the other matrix movies as well we
had a big training time so we get this
this luxury of spending all this time
together working together
and then when you show up on set
there's already this foundation built in
but the first day that we both worked we
were in the same scene but we just sort
of crossed paths and i thought it was a
really gentle wave um
i felt like
i was glad it wasn't like a big scene i
just got to kind of get into her
walk by
a few times
um but it felt really good what about
you keanu yeah it was uh yeah it was it
was wonderful to uh to be there and to
start so what did lana say um when you
guys were coming back with these
characters what i know we can't talk
that much about what's going on but
where did she say neo was in this moment
where we sort of reached
um
yeah she didn't she kind of left that up
to me
in the sense that
she didn't kind of download her whole
perspective of the character and stuff
it was
more about
here's the story here's the script and
then you know if i had any questions and
stuff she would answer them um what
about you carrie anne
it's a little bit i think different with
trinity this time around she i feel
she's trinity but there's like so much
more complexity even more so than neo
did you guys talk about any of that like
maybe that there's a little bit of a
shift a bigger shift with trinity this
time around i don't think i don't think
we had that specific conversation
i mean it's definitely on the page uh in
her writing and
but we didn't really have she doesn't we
don't really
she's not that kind of director to talk
in that way
i i don't exactly know how to describe
it but you really bring
you you want to give her what she what
she has written on the page you want to
just bring that to life and she really
creates the environment for that to
happen
we didn't have a lot of um
talks about it to be honest
awesome well i guess something you do
have to talk a lot about is the fight
scenes because they're like these very
intricate dance dances that you guys
sort of do together and carry and i'll
start with you
if you can going back into it what was
the most complicated scene you'd have to
give details on it but like which one
was it and how long did you guys prepare
for it we prepared for like the six
weeks or eight weeks before we started
shooting and then we would continue
training um when we weren't shooting for
things that were coming up
um what was the most difficult is that
what you asked like the most challenging
most challenging yeah most challenging
time around or did you get to do
something that you never did before
yeah um doing the rooftop was something
that i had never done before so that was
pretty challenging uh physic it wasn't
really challenging physically so much as
it was challenging mentally
so that that was interesting to overcome
that kind of fear
around doing that particular piece of
action and keanu for you i feel like
every time you come back for any action
role whether it's this or don't lick or
anything else you always try to like i
think up the ante and the matrix was
known for being such a groundbreaking
thing in the world of stunt choreography
was there anything sort of
new that you tried to throw at this one
or something more like revisiting
something from the previous films
yeah i mean i guess it's revisiting
i don't know when you do something
you're familiar with it are you
revisiting it i don't know
um
yeah it was uh it was just fun to get
back into it uh in terms of something
new
uh
it's so hard i know
i mean
i don't know i don't know i don't have
anything kind of super shiny to look at
in terms of new i would just say it's uh
um
it's just matrix action it's matrix
action that's fair um well this is
actually ranked very high on our most
anticipated like the rotten tomatoes
fans have voted it is the one as one of
the movies that they're most excited to
see
if you
could sort of preview for them what they
should be most excited that's new this
time around what would you tell them to
get ready for and carry on i'll start
with you oh he's so much better at this
than i i don't know let's go let's go
new characters we have new characters in
the matrix world we have a love story we
have great action great action we have
us versus them
we have ideas of
human kinds and and humankind and
machines technology coming together what
is reality who are we what are we doing
and you see so an incredible story that
i think can be a part of who we are in
our lives
and it's entertaining as heck it's a
crazy wonderful ride
buckle up strap in and enjoy oh that is
so good yeah no i'm with it all right so
this is the last question because
they're they're gonna get me out of here
and i have to ask it even though i know
you guys aren't probably gonna say it
but
this
maybe alludes to more chapters uh yet to
come
what are your thoughts carrie anne
we don't i mean we don't i i have no
knowledge of that so i'm not really
entertaining that
i'm enjoying right where i am right now
celebrating the you know this film
okay yeah i knew you weren't gonna say
anything okay so then i'll do this i'll
just flip it on you keanu what can you
tell me about john wick
i'm just gonna ask you about movies that
i know you can't answer john wick is
gonna be awesome and i don't know if
there's going to be another matrix story
but we have one now
i think it's a really cool film
for our times in our days
they taught you good
made you believe their world was all you
deserved
but some part of you knew that was a lie
some part of you remembered what was
real
well the first thing i definitely want
to start with is just the matrix on both
of you because both of you are coming
into the franchise as
new interpretations of previous maybe
iterations so what impact did the matrix
have on you yaya first then when did you
first see it
i saw it for the first time probably
around the time that it came out i don't
recall seeing it in the theater i was
really like an outside kid i was
i was i wasn't a big big a big movie kid
but when i did see it i i hadn't forgot
about it after that uh i remember the
big action sequences i remember uh you
know the fight in the dojo i remember
you know lawrence fishburne being so
damn cool with his morpheus and the ali
shuffle
and the fight scenes and the bending of
the spoon it was just there was
something in it for everybody and i just
i laughed it all up i didn't see it in
the theater i rented it
with my friends from blockbuster video
on vhs
yeah yes
and
we were all blown away by it and
it really was my it started my love
affair with the wachowskis and then i
would see every film that they
made after that
and uh
even like all the way up until sense8
you know the matrix started my kind of
like obsession with them i literally
feel like lana was just like all right
we're just gonna make this a family
reunion and get everyone back together
um
but then they've done reinterpretations
of of previous people so yaya you play
let's allude a virgin morpheus
homage i don't want to get too much into
it but
you loved lawrence's portrayal how much
of that did you use towards this new
character or did you throw that all out
and just try to find it new
no i think um i use some of it i use as
much as i found was uh was was useful
um but also you know my character wanted
to be different you know my character
probably
my character would probably look at that
morpheus and say that that morpheus was
very serious you know he would probably
have a bit of fun you know uh poking fun
at you know that at the tone you know at
how how stern he was you know my and and
and my character wanted to
you know exist in a different space he
wanted to do the complete opposite and
loosen up and and to be
vibrant with his colors and with his
style and with his attitude you know in
a very
2020 version but it was always my job to
pay
homage to you know the footsteps that i
was walking in you know and so i
borrowed just enough you know to uh to
make sure that i kept the integrity of
that character um but also leaving
enough space to to open up and play into
you know to make my own version yeah
especially with those suits but we'll
get into that in a minute um
jonathan
uh your character in the trailer looks
like there is a intense parallel to
agent smith let's just say that so
i'm just curious
in some of that you got to maybe play up
things differently like this the way you
played your character this time around
i'm really trying here what did you want
to play up that was new because i feel
like he really embraced his campsite
your character absolutely absolutely and
it was clear from the script and from
initial conversations with lana that
she wasn't wanting either of us to do
an impression of what came before and
that this was kind of
a new programming version of what had
happened previously
um there there are certain homages to
to the original in in my character and i
did spend
a lot of time watching
youtube clips of some specific youtube
clips of
the of the previous films and
tapping into the intensity of the
fighting
was was a real key in for my character
uh and then we played it was it was a
very playful creative environment with
lana and we all kind of found it
together and i will just say this as a
bit of a broadway kid how much fun was
all of your scenes with neil patrick
harris like i was just living for every
time y'all were together
totally totally i know it like i i
i grew up watching him admiring him and
it was so cool to act with him
yeah um yeah you get to have a lot of
fun too let me just say boy the costume
department did you write with those
suits
but
i mean what was your favorite did you
guys have conversations because it
really does i think inform the character
that we meet versus the character we see
sorry that that neo meets versus the
character we meet in in the very
beginning of the film like the suits are
part of his
evolution really yeah yeah i mean
um i didn't have i didn't have feedback
about about the fashion in fact i came
in wanting to you know when i did bring
my feet you know my my input it was it
was really pushing pushing it a lot
further i mean i wanted to come in with
my hair or dye red with the cool parts
and things like that
um and uh lana was like now we're not
gonna quite go that far
still need to get that ball head about
you
but uh
but uh when you rock it
but the fashion was you know the the
fashion was definitely a big part of
this character like i said you know he
was stepping into a world where he was
trying to figure out how he how he fit
in and you know i think one of the
the first thing that people see when you
walk through the door
but one of the first things is is
what you're wearing you know how you how
you dress yourself in and what you're
wearing says about you know about about
your mood and how you feel and what
you're going after so he was
a character or or a person who had
probably blended in with the rest of the
world for a very long time and stepping
into this new iteration of himself
uh he wanted to stand out for sure
[Music]
priyanka i'll start with you what is it
like joining the matrix franchise and
i'll add this one who's the most excited
um to hear you be cast in this one i
think i know
um i think my family was very excited my
team but more than anything i was very
excited why does everybody like bypass
my excitement
you know like i was psyched
but um i was super excited i think i was
most excited because i felt like you
know it was
um i think it's really an honor to
be given an opportunity to be part of
something that is such a legacy
franchise i mean i remember being in my
late teens when it came out and i
remembered shifting pop culture so
viscerally
um that it was just really cool to have
a chance to play with such an incredible
ensemble cast and also have the reprised
um roles of obviously carrie anne um
keanu and jada and to be able to watch
all of that it was just really cool to
immerse myself into something that as a
teenager i was really
excited about yeah i know it's
incredible and jessica and both of you
have been involved with very big movies
and franchises before but this one i
imagine joining it had to feel different
right
you know i don't think it it i don't
think i fully grasped
i don't think i fully grasped it um
i don't i don't know it didn't hit me
until
afterwards after we'd filmed it
and then i was like oh gosh this film
is in the hearts of so many people there
you know the original like you said it
changed pop culture but you were also a
baby when the movie came out the first
one yeah and i mean i loved it i was
obsessed with it but i don't think i
really went oh my god it's the matrix
until after i think that was
self-preservation yeah that's probably a
good way to be i mean your character we
do know that um she is one of the people
that is on the mission to sort of get
neo from the trailers and find him and
figure it out what do you think if you
ask bugs your character mio means to her
what would she say
i think neo is a symbol of hope i yeah
he
he was the one who who started the
revolution and and
without him bugs wouldn't be
wouldn't be the woman that she is
yeah and then priyanka your character
not to give too much away folks don't
know already but she um
is part of the original trilogy and so
where do we find her now that's
different
well um
i can talk about what obviously we know
because in the original trilogy you see
sathi's character
you know being
being under the care of the oracle and
you know there was a foreshadowing about
her having
some
special journey in you know some special
something in in neo's journey and also
um she would be she would bring peace
between humans and machines so all of
that foreshadowing existed and we had
left her as a child and now we find her
you know waiting for this moment for her
whole life and preparing for this moment
her whole life and she intercepts
the mission
this is a little bit easier to navigate
because it's always difficult with
movies like this with all the cgi and
everything but what was the most fun day
to shoot and they might be different so
jessica i'll start with you what was the
best day to shoot the most fun the one
you want to definitely you know snap a
mental picture for um
when i auditioned i had to audition with
the scene between bugs and neo
and it's quite heartfelt and
because of covert we got shut down so
that the time i by the time i actually
got to film that scene it had been you
know 10 months so the anticipation was
high just to get it done just to do it
and i'd been sitting with those lines
for so long and then at the end of the
day keanu came over and came over and
shook my hand and was like you did a
great job and it was yeah he was so so
lovely about it oh it's sweet uh and
then priyanka what about you what was
your favorite day on set
i was just terrified the whole time man
i was just like i want to keep my head
above water i just
come out on the other side
i think this is the most fun moment
you're like
talking about having done it yeah
that's fair that's fair okay well i'll
ask this to you jessica because
obviously we saw how incredible you are
with stunt choreography in iron fist i
mean you're still getting shout outs on
your on your fight and stunt
choreography on that which one was
harder to prepare for were they about
the same
in a way iron fist was hard because i i
wasn't that good i wasn't good at
martial arts and i hadn't really trained
extensively in it and so
that was hard but i was also younger and
my body was better
and so this time i had the injuries that
i'd picked up over the years from the
other projects
and my body was slower
and so i think this time this time was
harder even though i had trained more
yeah
wow that's interesting to put it um
because i'm thinking that my body
wouldn't have been up for either of it
so i'm glad
um
i'll ask you this i mean it hasn't been
explicitly said but i mean the fact that
we're getting a fourth one alludes to
the fact that there might be more
stories to tell within the matrix would
you want to continue on
of course i would love to be a part of
you know this iconic franchise but i
don't know if there's another one being
made do you know this
i have no idea
if you find out anything about that do
let us know i've had i've had nothing
you know the internet are about my
favorite like i have i don't know
anything anyway so yeah yeah okay
very last one before they get out here
real quick jessica what do you hope
audiences take from this new version
i mean i hope that they love it i think
it's expanding on the conversations and
topics that were so relevant in the
first one and have become more relevant
now today but i also think that it's
adding a sense of hope and
and brightness that is kind of necessary
right now
you